so if you're thinking about starting
YouTube in 2024 maybe trying to revive
your Channel or just scale your channel
in this video I'm going to be talking
about seven tips right up front here
that are going to help you come up with
better video ideas to cut through the
noise and all the competition let's face
it YouTube has more videos being posted
every day than ever before and so how do
you find topics and angles to cut
through the noise I want to share seven
things with you and then today is a Q&A
episode so if you are watching on the
replay you can check out time codes and
chapters and see some of the topics that
we covered because the big theme of
today is how do you start right how do
you avoid the pain and the frustration
of just spinning your wheels on YouTube
and being frustrated when you're not
getting views when it's discouraging
when subscriber growth is slow and when
it just feels like man how can I be
different how can I stand out we're
going to be covering those topics today
now this episode of the coffee with
kenel show is brought to you by VR
podcast.com there is a limited time left
to actually get one of the few sales a
year that we do like this on our YouTube
system called video ring Academy so
check that out on the show notes but
more on that later and let me just cover
these um seven tips right up front so
inside of our program video ranking
Academy we go through a seven-step
system okay we've developed a system
it's one of the things that makes uh
what we do different than what everybody
else is doing because a lot of times
people have good information they got a
tactic here a strategy here a piece of
advice here but it's not a system so we
have a seven-step system and we go about
50 hours deep into this inside of our
main course but in this video I want to
talk about the Second Step which is
research after you reverse engineer and
start with the end in mind the second
step is research but what does research
mean in a 2024 World and what are some
of the ways that we can research and by
the way if you have a question put four
questions question marks before and
after it and um we will start those and
I will be answering your questions here
shortly but we have seven layers of
research or seven angles of research
that can help you come up with video
ideas you're not thinking of right now
and opportunities to get views that I
would call lwh hanging fruit but that
most people can't see and we're not
going to break down everyone in detail
but I'll explain what they are so number
one is audience research one of the most
important things to understand is who is
your target audience and then you want
to start
asking like what is it they really want
what are the demographics of your target
audience what are the psychographics of
your target audience I would argue in
2024 psychographics are a lot more
important demographics are going to be
age ethnicity and it's powerful to get
clear that you know my channels for Gen
X and Baby Boomers um females that um
are maybe of this skin type or hair
color if it was makeup or beauty you
know you started getting specific and
maybe some demographic type of thing but
psychographics what other channels do
they follow what are they into what are
the kind of groups they follow like ways
of thinking like do they have political
opinions do they have religious opinions
that' be like the psychographic so so
thinking about audience research and the
mistake that like most creators make is
they don't really have a clear audience
or they think they do it's like two
words it's like uh it's like a channel
for women you're like okay bro like you
might want to go a little bit deeper and
so uh audience research is kind of a
first layer of really getting to
understand your audience this can go
through asking questions um and there's
all kinds of layers we could go into but
for time sake let's hit number two now
keyword research keyword research is the
second one this would be where we're
actually using tools like vid IQ and we
go not just just find keywords which
would be like the search phrases a key
word would be like the word diet a
keyword phrase would be like best diet
for women over 40 it's a whole phrase
but that is a keyword phrase then your
question is how much search volume per
month does this topic does this keyword
phrase have and so the powerful thing
about actually doing keyword research is
you're also now going to look for data
in fact every one of these you could
have data because you could have data
about what's happening with Gen X women
you know what's happening with Gen Z
youth pastors like knowing your audience
but then keyword research is you're
looking for specific Search terms like
how many people are searching for this a
month and that's going to give you
feedback of what video you should make
next now another layer could be topic
research and the difference there would
be okay keyword research May point you
to there's a lot of interest interest
in kids ministry ideas for 5-year-olds
or for a particular age age range you're
like oh wow there's like a thousand
people a month or thousands of people a
month searching for that but then the
conclusion after that isn't that you're
G to make that exact video what it's
actually going to lead you to is a topic
so some people say keyword research is
dead and they're wrong but some people
would say okay it's less about keyword
research where I would agree with them
is like it's not that it's less about
keyword research it's that it's about
understanding what are people really
looking for what are they interested in
what are they searching for and then
following that path of breadcrumbs to
maybe a topic that isn't so literally a
keyword but that becomes a powerful
topic for your next video and so that's
kind of the difference it's like you're
you're actually just kind of sourcing
topics there's we can talk about a
hundred different strategies for doing
that but uh you're finding what are the
best topics and again out of your next
500 video ideas not that you got 500 but
out of not that I know how to select the
right camera angle but out of your next
you know what what what are your next 10
videos what are your next 100 videos a
lot of times people make videos that
just aren't that great and I'm not even
too titling thumbnail and content I'm
like the topic itself is just I wouldn't
have made that next I probably wouldn't
even made that maybe ever like I like
find a better topic and so the powerful
thing about doing your research first
why we would say research before you
press record is so that you're better
positioned uh to get better results now
Community questions this would be where
you uh start listening the best content
creators are the best audience listeners
I think one of the biggest mistakes that
happens and I know we get busy and if
you're a parent like me or you're in
school or something you know I got a
three-year-old and a one-year-old just
like trying to get the the checklist off
of the day done it's hard enough isn't
it like we're just trying to survive out
here like we're just trying to trying to
make it and so the to like the must do
list is like I gotta shoot the video and
I gotta plan the video and I gotta
upload it and then I gotta put the trash
and recycling out tonight and then I
gota pick up my parents from the airport
you know you just think about you're
just trying to survive and so what can
fall to the Wayside is engaging in
comments reading comments and really
deep engaging in the community because
in a way nobody would know if you didn't
do it you know like you could get away
like you still posted a video you still
put your content out there but a lot of
times where creators results start going
downhill is because there becomes a
widening gap between where they're at
and the connection with the actual
Community reading comments getting
feedback like if I'm real transparent
with you like sometimes I think even on
our own team we can sometimes get a
little bit dist on the YouTube comments
CU it's hard to keep up with them too
there's a lot of them where we want to
read comments on every video and
sometimes listen to the critiques the
feedback the pain points people saying
like I didn't fully understand that and
that gives you insight into the next
move so the better we listen the more we
connect in the comments the more we
listen now your objection might be Sean
I'm brand new I don't even get comments
yet I'm not gonna let you off the hook
this is the coffee with candle show man
I got my
columia prea coffee Ro poers Watermelon
candy cantaloupe guava are the notes on
this blend if you were interested in
picking it up linking that I'm just
kidding I'm trying to get a coffee
sponsor not really I suppose but I guess
the coffee with kenel show should have a
coffee sponsor but I'm not GNA let you
off the
hook if you would say I don't get any
comments yet because if you've done
audience research that means you know
who your target audience is that means
you should know where they hang out and
where they are commenting in the YouTube
channels they are watching and where
they are engaging in the Reddit threads
or Facebook groups or Discord groups and
you should be an active participant in
those communities so in doing so there's
absolutely Zer zero excuse for why you
couldn't get audience insights so you
could be making videos based on the
questions that are being posted in the
comment sections of your competitor's
Channel let's go to number five okay
number five Trend analysis so this would
tools like Google Trends is something
trending up is it trending down and you
want to have a steady resource or a
steady flow of what's trending coming
your way this I suppose is kind of a
skill set and it's a muscle you develop
over time but it always surprises me
when someone's in a particular industry
like like they're in parenting or their
YouTube channel is about parenting and
they're unaware of the top five to 10
blogs written blogs in parenting they
don't know the top 5 to 10 podcasts
about parenting they're not following
the top 5 to 10 Instagram accounts about
the latest trends or psychology and
parenting they're not reading like like
you got to be in your industry so like
when I say trends like you want to be in
your industry actually living it
consuming it even if you're not flying
to the conferences and events why aren't
you looking at the Recaps online so why
aren't you like really actually in the
trends but then also you should be
thinking about macro Trends as a side
note two of the big strategies we teach
inside of uh video ranking Academy are
uh full-on course and where we go deeper
into these is Trend surfing and
influence surfing
and you can actually combine those under
a term that I would call culture
surfing like your awareness of what's
happening in the culture like it would
be your awareness of what's happening
this year it's an election year um I was
just thinking you know I'm going to make
a podcast about five to 10 things
content creators could learn from Donald
Trump triggered you know five to 10
things people could learn from Joe Biden
or m Michelle Obama who's gonna run
who's gonna run for the I don't know
who's gonna run on the left uh and so
and and so equal opportunities here at
think media as far as because there's
things to learn from both sides but you
might be saying okay Sean what are you
doing that' be culture surfing what's
happening this year man it's election
year here in the US so so what's
happening in culture and so Trend
analysis would just be saying okay
what's trending where are things going
what's happening and and the mistake I
think people make is they're like Sean
I'm not
trendy like I'm not you know wearing the
latest I don't like I don't have a
Stanley mug how dare I not have a
Stanley on this
stream okay you know Niche Trend anybody
anybody got a Stanley out there the big
okay how dare I not have a think media
patterned custom Stanley all right
relax Trend analysis culture serving
what's happening in culture so it's it's
part of paying attention and having a
flow of information which I kind of
touched on this number six could be like
industry research industry research so
industry research again would be what is
your industry and how much time are you
spending actually looking inside of
what's happening in your industry what
are some of the newest things who are
the who are the experts in the industry
and what what is some of the newest
stuff coming from them like how many
books have you read on your topic in the
last you know three to six months like
you know your psychology Channel
parenting Channel DIY and you and and I
know books might sound old school and
you're like why would I go old school
It's All Digital I've just found that
when you dig into a physical book that's
really rich in terms of the research and
the quality that's maybe even just
adjacently related to your YouTube
channel chances are you're going to have
a journal full of 5 to 10 next video
ideas and you're going to have just
little things popping off related to
that but again what does industry
research mean it means you're you're
paying attention to your research what
are the events what are the workshops
what are the Publications what are the
magazines what are the blogs what are
the podcasts again you go listen I
promise you you take your Niche you find
the top podcasts you go listen to like
one episode from each of them with a
journal out if you don't get a video
idea you're probably in the wrong
industry because it's because if you're
when you get aligned with where your
passion is and where a little bit of
experience is I'm not saying you have to
be an expert right but like where you've
got some experience in it then like
ideas will start popping off and let me
know if this is actually valuable and if
you're on the replay we're only six in
we got a seventh one and then I'm going
to hit Q&A but I hope you could see that
what I've noticed most people don't even
do a quarter of this they barely do this
at all or a lot of times they don't
really research at all research before
you press record start coming up with
better and stronger video ideas and then
start getting more views as a result
which then finally number seven would be
a competitor analysis a competitor
analysis sometimes you know one of my
least favorite messages is in the
Creator economy maybe business is
everyone quotes comparison is a thief of
Joy can we stop it
I mean I know it's true but like can we
relax like that one has who oh
comparison is the thief of Joy I like to
say comparison is the thief of joy and
the killer of creativity and I agree
with that message that message couldn't
be more powerful because if you're
comparing people and you and you feel
insignificant because of who you're
following on Instagram or they're
growing faster than me or I wish I had
like all of that could be toxic I think
the problem is though that has set so
many people up for failure and is that
you actually stopped comparing I
actually think comparison is the path to
wisdom comparison is essential for
business owners and entrepreneurs and
smart content creators
comparison is actually seeing what else
is out there in the market so you can
adapt your strategy accordingly it would
be incredibly foolish not to be studying
and analyzing the competitors novices
with you
know with Hyper
sensitivity are afraid of comparing and
again if it leads you to insecurity and
all that kind of stuff I think that's
the thing to to deal with that's not
what I'm talking about and I'm not
talking about an issue of like worth
here or something I'm talking about
we're in a competitive landscape you
better be aware of some of the Dynamics
happening around you so you can
strategize accordingly so competitor
analysis is key because again in
business this is a classic one is USP
you know type that one out USP you ever
heard of it before what's it stand for
Unique selling proposition it means your
unique angle on why you're different how
you're different how your Channel's
different hard to come up with you might
feel like oh there's nothing original
King Solomon said nothing's new Under
the Sun there's no new things anymore
okay it's tough that's how that's why
you got to work hard but you can find
something you know how many YouTube
educations people are out there okay
cool so Sean why are you different well
many reasons I think we have the biggest
faculty in terms of inside of our group
and whatnot we've got the support and um
kind of like Community the most vibrant
like group and there's there could be
things like that but if I said what's
the biggest reason we're different is
because most people are just teaching
random tactics that are good their
information is good tactics here
strategy here a few tips some good
information if you can apply that but I
nobody's got a system like one of the
things that makes this different is you
don't rise to the level of your goals
you fall to the level of your systems so
having a system that's a repeatable
process that you can use to reach
success it makes us different like that
nobody and and here's a couple business
words for you smart business owners in
the education space they come up with
Frameworks they come up with a propri
rary process you ever heard somebody say
that before maybe not but they come up
with like oh our proprietary process
because you might say what is it you do
who what and why what is it you do I
help people grow their YouTube channels
it's not unique there's other people who
do it okay why like how do you do it
this is how we start cutting out
difference how do we do it well we do it
with what's called our Sr think media
system and nobody else has the approach
and the methodology that we have to
Growing ranking videos creating passive
income so our how is different and then
the other level that is different would
be our why and Simon synic said start
with why like we do it because we're
like perp you know to help one million
purpose-- driven people create a
full-time living doing what they love
while making a difference in the world
with YouTube and with to have that
success without losing your soul I've
heard zero people say that their mission
is to help people grow their YouTube
channels and experience that success
without losing their soul that's
different and you might go this guy's
kind of religious I am like my faith is
huge for me I'm out of here great I mean
I'm probably we're definitely probably
not going to be a good fit we might be
incompatible you know swipe left or
right I don't know what you do on dating
apps been married too many years but um
you know swipe and find somebody else
but when you share your why that'll
resonate but what's your how what's your
how your USP your unique selling
proposition I kind of broke that down
from how we do it at think media to
encourage you to study your competitors
because you're like how do they do it
what is their way of doing it what is
their way of creating content what is
their way of doing videos what are some
things and then in light of that
analysis how can I be different that's
kind of a side quest because ultimately
here we're talking about research and
competitor analysis would also be going
to practically number one actually
knowing who your competitors are which a
lot of people haven't even taken the
time to really think about that doing
this would be market research you're
you're you're doing a competitive anal
analysis you wouldn't open up a
restaurant in a city without seeing what
other restaurants in the city what other
taco shops are there if you hadn't but
maybe you would and that's the problem
is you didn't actually research ahead is
the city growing or dying is there new
developments are people moving there is
the is the market growing um what what
are the demographics in the city would
there be people interested in tacos I am
interested in tacos you got a taco I'm
starving right now is there people and
then what locations where what are the
traffic patterns like where should we
open it oh this this place for lease is
on discount well maybe there's a reason
it's on discount because nobody goes to
that side of town or you didn't realize
that someone just got stabbed over there
and that one street over just a little
sketch so nobody actually even if the
tacos are good people don't want to risk
their life to go to that part of town
competitor analysis looking ahead so
you're looking at okay what on other
people's channels um what are maybe some
of their top videos top topics what are
some things I can learn there what are
something that's maybe proven to get
views that I could do a unique spin on
that'd be competitor analysis so again
we cover this deeper uh in other places
but I hope those are valuable which one
do you like best is any of these new to
you have have you done any of these
before and can you add any value uh on
the replay uh to maybe some topics or
tools you use because this is a
community right so here on our think
media podcast Channel and we do the
coffee with canel show check out the
comment section because iron sharpens
iron so you know which of these do you
like best is there any tools you use to
do any of these did are any of these a
aha moment did any of these stand out to
you let me know and uh I want to say
welcome to the coffee with canel show
we're going to do some Q&A but I'm super
fired up to be hanging out with you
today I'm going to take a sip of coffee
and then we'll get into
[Music]
it
you know technically that was a 21
minute and 35 second hook I mean like
because this is actually the content so
that was like the intro so welcome to
that was the introduction I just thought
I'd RI on something and hopefully it was
valuable and so let me know if you got
some value but uh I appreciate you
Swedish car guy and uh yeah who's
drinking coffee let me know what you're
drinking um I'm out here on my second
cup of the day uh I appreciate that you
appreciate the tangents uh the wolf
speaks because that's that's just how my
brain works I want a taco as well um I
need some good tacos there's this place
in Las Vegas called Taco e
taco and they've got it all like the
langua so you can get you know the
tongue you get tripe you get the whole
thing anybody here like f I'm a big Fu
guy and uh and I get it all so you have
the soft tendon you got the tripe you
got the meatball you got the the marbled
steak or you got the different steak you
got the premium Meats anybody into that
okay we got water and working out here 7
am on in Australia it's tomorrow in
Australia so thank you for being here
from the future let us know if we're
going to be okay give us heads up if if
if we're gonna be okay because you're
already living in tomorrow I agree fuzz
amazing uh Gaston and uh Hey pod sounds
schol appreciate you you can always
reach out to uh our team uh they can
give you you some info think Medias
support.com actually and send us some
details about your pod would' love to
consider all right let's hit some of
your questions and if you got a question
put four question marks before and after
and uh how much do you think AI will
affect content creators in
2024 I think that um I think that in
2024 AI is going to be a big deal I see
a couple things happening here right now
though I do think number one there's a
little bit of AI fatigue it's just been
so hyped and there so many tools and
there's so many startup AI companies and
it's so overwhelming because it's like
there's a lot of like a land grab AI is
such a new frontier so I think on the
one hand it's it's overwhelming and I
don't blame you if you feel a little
fatigued let me know do you feel a
little fatigued about AI like man some
of the tools and they kind of get you
started but now I like feel stuck
because I'm 45 minutes into this but
it's not perfect and now I still feel
like I have a lot of work to do and I
feel like if I would have just started
without doing this I could be further so
I think that there's it's a little bumpy
out there it's the the promise of
AI
is like it's this magic pill and of
course you eventually live long enough
to know there really are no magic pills
um you know secondly though I would say
2024 the smartest content creators are
going
to embrace that overwhelm and work
through the frustrations with AI and
establish systems and routines and tools
that consistently help them go
faster so we were big on Focus here at
think media we talk about how the power
focus and killing distraction so it's
always the worst mistake when it comes
to success in any
area to buy 10
books have them all come to to your
house and then be so overwhelmed that
you like read the first chapter of two
of them and then they all sit there and
you don't even know which one to read
next the better move is to read one book
it's always a mistake to get a be a part
of like 10 programs as opposed to being
a part of one so I think that's the big
key for AI would be
like if you're in a rush to download
every app and try every tool and you
know get ever like I want to be on the
bleeding edge I don't want to miss
anything ultimately that can just lead
to overwhelm and in action and it
doesn't end up really working so I think
smart graders are absolutely going to
embrace Ai and to your
question um it's going to give them an
advantage it's going to help them go
faster and and time management is more
important than ever before in a very
distracted world I think it's attention
management time
management um managing your willpower
willpower is fleeting every day there's
also decision fatigue
how many decisions do you these are like
psychological it's like the science of
that we're seeing and so being really
guarding your focus in terms of your
time management your energy management
where you're focusing choosing how many
decisions you're making in a day and
willpower and focusing all of that but
those who lean into AI I think um I
think it's it'd be a mistake to not be
leaning into um
AI um thinkb Team I've got a
question I have never seen a video on H
about how to
when you're downloading and that info
forgive me I don't can you reword the
question maybe we get that one back in
there I didn't understand the question
next one girl dad Chronicles how much
damage does it cause when crossposting
over all the social media
channels I don't think causes any
damage um but let's define the proper
way to quote unquote
crosspost
so
generally
the question is like should I promote
maybe my YouTube videos across all my
social media channels and the general
best practice is that if you were to
take your Facebook page and you post a
YouTube video link there it doesn't
perform very well why because you're
sending people off of the platform and
Facebook's goal is to keep people on the
platform YouTube's goal is to keep
people on the platform and so
crossposting if you're just posting a
YouTube link can generally be pretty
ineffective now the better way is to
post natively which would mean let's say
you took your YouTube video downloaded
it or took the file and uploaded it to
Facebook all things being equal that
would perform a lot better and it would
allow people to stay on the platform the
question for you becomes why do that
it's not going to help you get ad
Revenue it's not going to help you grow
your YouTube channel and it probably
won't even be that effective and
breaking out on Facebook's its own
challenge or whatever so so then that
becomes kind of a best practice I think
the next thing to consider is just what
are the best practices of each platform
like what do people really do like how
much are they going Link in BIO clicks
on Instagram generally are over are are
down um link stickers on Instagram
stories generally are down in 2024 you
might see people who say like comment we
do that I'll be like comment you know
Challenge and I'll send you a link to
the challenge and you can actually just
do it manually you don't need fancy
software to do that you can just do it
and then everybody that comments just
message them but using something like
many chat to to that's what's that's a
big 2024 strategy that's working
and one funnel strategy I could give you
is you
creating a good Instagram reel which
that would be up to you to think about
what's the hook what's a little bit of
value and then what's a way to say and
hey if you're interested in going deeper
just comment podcast and I'll send you a
link to the full
podcast now you're sharing a link to
your podcast but it's happening in DMS
it's kind of permission based you've
already kind of teed up the relationship
on
Instagram but in such a way that that
people want to engage with it and then
from their DMS they can click so that
would just be like a better way so I
think it's mastering and figuring out
best practices and that that's kind of
overwhelming friends I mean so back to
guard your focus one of our biggest
pieces of of advice for new creators is
to be careful on social media to almost
avoid it mostly altogether when you're
just growing your YouTube channel like
for we've had a lot of people that have
been um jumping into video ranking
Academy and I'm like put the blinders on
Master the system rank videos connect it
to passive income streams get money for
the mission get your foundation solid
keep doubling down on that keep ranking
videos build on YouTube stay on YouTube
Master YouTube go deeper on YouTube
build on YouTube go deeper get money
coming in hire an editor okay and then
maybe start to expand your vision I
think if you've got like your main
platform YouTube and one or two other
social platforms that you're posting on
fine as a solo Creator but man focus is
power like really thinking about that
and here's the funny thing man in 2024
I'm not going to call them out this is a
true story so I commented actually on a
friend of mine who I used to freelance
for this was like 10 years ago and I was
social media person this was this didn't
work 10 years ago and I was shocked that
this is what happened so I just
commented on this video which was like a
clip of the full YouTube video and
whoever this person's social media
manager was I kid you not God is my
witness replied to my comment with a
YouTube
link now you might be like what's the
big deal well number one that person
should be fired I mean like legit it
sounds harsh but like if if you
literally you're calling yourself a
social media manager you can't click
links in Instagram
comments it's not like I've seen I've SE
I see this happen a lot on like
Instagram and sometimes unfortunately
it's like churches and Ministries that's
why we have such a heart to like help
churches and pastors and Ministries
everybody too but it's like man people
need help dog like it's it's dark out
there and not just people don't just
need you know the hope of the Gospel
they need they need help because how are
you gonna even hear if you can't click
the link you get to the YouTube video so
what's so funny is this person could
have um DMD me and said hey if you want
to check out the full video on YouTube
because again it was a real of this
person on Instagram but I just commented
and they posted a YouTube link and
seriously you know I'll be like just
chilling some nights you know and I'll
see that and all of a sudden I'm like
stressed for that I it's not even my
business it's not even my but I'm like
what are we do
what do we do I started getting anx
anxiety like my blood pressure is rising
for somebody else's I'm like 2024
January you're posting a just a you
youtube.com XY
25652 on Instagram like you
can't I'm not gonna type that's the
funny thing what do you what am I gonna
type that in what what are you
doing and if you're a leader and you're
looking for a YouTube channel manager or
something to manage your social media or
you're trying to think about man be be
careful a lot of people out here with
the social media
agency what sorry I'm veering off but
here's the question is just again how
much
damage that the bottom line it's not
that it's damaged it's just that it's I
would say it's ineffective for 99% of
people and not because it is ineffective
but it's because they don't understand
the best practices of each platform they
don't have the bandwidth team resources
or systems to sustain it you want to say
f focus at the start in my book YouTube
Secrets second edition we wrote a whole
new chapter we completely reframed our
views on social media and we talked
about three
seasons that you need to self-define and
tell me interactive on the chat that you
could be in in your YouTube Journey
here's the three seasons number one side
hustle number two solopreneur number
three scale let me know which one are
you in you can type number one two or
three so number one is the side Hustle
season full-time job you've got a
business you've got or no you got work
you've got or you got a business you're
a full-time realator and you're in a
side Hustle season because all of the
efforts to build your YouTube channel
are in the extra hours or there on this
side now number two is going to be the
solo preneur season and the solopreneur
season is where you've launched out and
you're able to work on on your online
business and your YouTube channel
fulltime but you're by yourself so not a
lot like some stuff has changed and it's
an incredible Milestone but it's still
tough because you're like and you know I
got so much to do and and if you do too
much in the solo preneur season you're
not going to last that long and and
you're going to get overwhelmed and
burnt out and then number three would be
scale which I would argue would be as
soon as you have at least one or two
contractors or some people starting to
work with you and you've established
even an assistant some level of Team
some level of systems and so we're it's
pretty cool to see I see we've got twos
here and we've got some ones here so
again when it comes to social media and
that question and that there's a whole
chapter on this and it is that if you're
in the solo preneur season one of the
biggest mistakes you can make is copying
people or doing what people in the scale
season are doing like people try to copy
Gary vaynerchuk like he says post like
82 pieces of content a day that's like
one of his messages like post three
times on LinkedIn and three times on
Instagram and you know what it's
actually a good message and it's not a
recipe for Burnout or overwhelm and the
mistake people make is they're like oh
he's just saying hustle endlessly to do
that no he's actually he has 20
full-time staff working on his personal
brand that's a different season than
you're probably in so when you're in the
side Hustle season or the solopreneur
season you want to be doing the right
strategies for this season that you're
in and making sure you avoid the
distractions and man I think where
people get mixed up is they're taking
tactics and strategies from different
seasons and it's not like the advice is
wrong the advice is right but the advice
is wrong for you right now and
so uh I hope that was helpful that was a
um few thoughts there and uh we'll get
into another question here and so two
maybe one 1.5 1.5 you got some money
coming in also a job so you maybe went
down to part-time or you could freelance
a little bit but you got some online
money coming in and so uh I love it good
conversations happening here and uh
depending on the season you're in that's
the strategy you're going to want to
apply part two like what are the
different parts we check offer Phil pret
turning the details of the video okay so
maybe this question
is how do you optimize a YouTube
video and what I would argue to keep it
simple is if YouTube gives you the
opportunity you should do it so one of
the biggest questions people have is
like do tags still matter do tags still
matter on YouTube and YouTube themselves
have said that they don't
carry much influence or barely any
influence in the performance of the
video
they said that the best use of tags is
for spelling Corrections or spelling
variations for example
maybe the way you're positioning video
your the video your name or the product
name has different spellings so you can
reinforce that in the tags so that
Google can index the video right that
could be one helpful thing um and so you
just have to understand the weight of a
particular field so I get the question a
lot about category which category should
I put my video in
and bottom line too it really doesn't
carry much
weight and it's not something you should
worry about it's like you want to Major
on the majors and minor on the minors
it's a minor thing however you should
pick the best category for the video
because once you get comfortable
following a system and optimizing your
YouTube videos like this stuff is fast
if you like okay it's in how-to and
style it's in education it's in whatever
it's like boom boom boom boom boom you
also have your auto you can save your
you can save a description template and
so and similar to tags tags are not only
um sh do I think you should do them I
think you use a tool like vid IQ which
you know by the way um wasn't going to
shout this out but you could check out
vid iq.com forth think if you're
interested in this and uh maybe um I can
uh maybe Drea can throw a a banner for
me in the coffee with canel and let me
just show you for example let me see
this video right here so we have a video
coming out on the fastest way to make
money with YouTube I don't even know
what this video is so Omar is in this
and using vid IQ I can come down here to
the tags and I could say well number one
I could say get tag suggestions which is
going to be I think based off the title
here and this is vid IQ AI
coach and uh while that's working I
could say how to make money on YouTube
so see how those pop up this is vid IQ
popping these up so I'm going to click
that because that's what the video is
about it's the fastest way to make money
on YouTube um and it looks like it's
generating tags from the video
transcript so it's doing some work here
on their AI side of things but watch how
fast this is as soon as you've got a
really clear idea of what it is you
click this little vid IQ logo and then
how to make money on YouTube without
making videos if that's not true I
wouldn't click it make money on YouTube
I'm going to click that and add that and
it just quickly adds it I'm going to
click this one okay here we go so let me
zoom out here so how to make money on
YouTube without making videos that is
not accurate how to make money on
YouTube make money online that would be
true how to make money online plus all
right make money make money Matt okay
YouTube automation unless they talk
about automation I'm not sure what they
talk about work from home how to make
money make money on YouTube 2022 so I
look at that one I'm gonna go okay uh
how to make money on YouTube
2024 okay why is my caps lock on and
then I'm going to say think
media um and I'm going to say at or I'm
going to say Omar
l toori so that's on there and then and
then so you see this and if I click
maybe think media I I could just how to
grow your YouTube channel not
necessarily true so punchline is when
you click this little thing here and
it's going to give you other like
relevant tags and then by the way look
at Old Tag suggestions which is a new
feature here
let's see YouTube monetization great
boom faceless Channel make making money
fast bang all right affiliate marketing
passive income
sure photography tutorials no oh so the
this is probably the topics because it
actually read the transcript to
recommend these so all that's kind of
cool so what did we just discover there
we discovered that um ultimately you can
quickly
do tags so on my typical video when I'm
optimizing a video tags take
me less than two minutes if not one
minute so pick your category pick your
tags get your title right get your stuff
right you know and so that's also why
this stuff with tools like this you know
come up here there's already a title on
this video it's maybe not the final
title fastest way to make money on
YouTube Boom get title suggestions tools
help you go faster and there was a AI
question earlier this is a this is a
great example of why AI saves you so
much time so now these are a couple
things simple strategies to sat cash on
YouTube uncover the secrets of YouTube
monetization fastest way to make money
on YouTube and then boom I can refresh
that again it's just going to throw me
titles right here so when you install
vid IQ vision and then when you which is
the plugin to Google Chrome that allows
you to see all this stuff and if you
want to try out the Boost plan make
money fast on YouTube the ultimate
formula and I could go boom use and just
put it right in there but I don't really
want to mess with whatever the
optimization is because Kyle's working
on this video separate from me so
anyways if you want to check that out
check that out and bottom line when it
comes to optimizing a video if it's if
YouTube gives you the option to do it
you should do it but do not get
distracted like those are the making the
better video doing the seven research
tips we talked at the beginning of this
video coming up with better topics
getting 1% better with every upload
definitely title and thumbnail those
things are the things that carry weight
and then do all the uh the description
stuff and if you use something like vid
IQ it's it's so fast that the Minor
Details you could just kind of check the
box it gives you a checklist uh like
like you want to you want your
optimization score over here on the
right see that little green you want
your optim my a title that evokes desire
is it clear what your video is about and
why is your title too long long and then
like lower priority stuff is over here
end screens the 200 like so so like
tools they'll help you go faster and if
you want to check out vid IQ vid iq.com
thinkink one Buck $1 try it out for a
month uh I think you'll love it it's a
tool that we definitely recommend our
program video ret Academy plus vid IQ is
like the power twins boom magic is made
okay let's hit your question by the way
today's episode is also brought to you
by uh V podcast.com which is just a
link uh that just takes you to uh an
offer on our course we just finished up
a challenge last week and it does end in
roughly 20 hours at the time of
recording live when we do these special
offers not like false scarcity or
anything we just have certain bonuses
certain extra things in there like our
YouTube road map Workshop um like couple
Niche Finder camera confidence um really
cool extra bonuses and if you are
interested in any of the stuff we're
talking about we'll put it all in the
description down below let me hit one of
the newer questions here do longtail T
keywords work in
tags yeah the longtail keywords are
essential in tags in my opinion what I
mean is this the worst tag is the tag
money that would be a key
word the better tag is how to make extra
money as an Uber
driver that is a keyword
phrase so what you're what you're
shooting for is how to
make money with Uber which is maybe
obvious with with Uber Eats so that that
right there is a key word phrase let's
check out this guy's video so your
driver mic let's click on it and then
let's see his tags and we'll see how vid
I Q ranks them so again I think the
mistake people make notice here on the
right side is the mistake people make is
they think that like this video ranks
number one because of the tags that's
the mistake but the tags are an
affirmation that you did all the other
stuff right and they are a reinforcement
because again I want all I want to check
all of the boxes in terms of my video
just being I want Google and YouTube
their little robots to be like perfect
we know where to file your video we know
how to position
your and they like put it in the right
place how could they know what your
video is
about if you don't say those things and
say those phrases in it and have them
titled and like reinforce it in the
description so I just want to reinforce
everything and then in doing so rank my
video
so see it says make more money on Uber
Eats that is a he ranks number one for
that and that is a longtail keyword it's
a keyword
phrase and the quote unquote worst tag
would be the tag Uber because it doesn't
even mean anything I mean it means
something but
like it's
2024 like I hope my video ranks for
Uber what how to get an Uber how to make
money on Uber Uber Eats is different
than Uber is driving Uber Eats worth it
like what's so really good question um
longtail is where it's at how important
are chapters and how many it's a good
question we could debate YouTube
chapters so let's do it so what are the
pros and cons of YouTube
chapters on the one hand YouTube
chapters are super powerful YouTube
gives us the opportunity to do it and I
think that they're a great way to serve
the viewer they make it easy for people
to see what content is Skip around in it
you'll notice a lot of long form
podcasts like Andrew Schultz flagrant
podcast I'm watching VI ROM Swan was
just on there good episode and like um
he breaks you can hover over and see the
different topics because it's also like
two and a half hours I'm like bro I
don't I going to watch the whole thing I
want to like maybe skip to a topic I'm
interested in so it's in service to the
viewer chapters help organize the
content they also are giving that's
another optimization checklist to give
reinforced
micro longtail
keywords what do I mean it's kind of a
geeky way of saying it you've got the
big topic of the video but you have
pieces that cover one particular thing
and while I'm not saying that they are
directly related there's a thing on
Google that says key moments like you
type in a Google search there's a
YouTube video there and it says key
moments and those key moments are parts
of the video that are SE searchable and
rankable and now findable and indexable
all on Google ranking so especially with
certain types of videos time codes and
chapters are incredible and again they
serve the viewer better let's talk about
the cons and the debate anti- chapters
is that it's going to hurt your watch
time it's going to make people leave the
video sooner it's going to make people
hover over and maybe skip off the video
or not stay as long and minutes matter
most on YouTube so I think it's more of
a tension to be managed rather than a
black and white answer to just make it's
either this or that I think it depends
on the video it depends on the context
we go a lot of layers deeper in like
ways of how you could structure them
whether you're like more overtly of what
it is or you just like you could
actually say what the tip is or you
could just say tip number one so people
can at least skip through the tips
YouTube if you check the box too
eventually will do auto chapters on
videos it usually doesn't happen unless
the video gets bigger but by default
that box is usually checked so even
YouTube is listening to the video
thinking about the different sections I
have key moments on uh like I think if
we go 2024 camera buying
guide I
think um yeah so I rank on
Google this is Google heard of it um so
this is Google 2024 camera buying guide
and I have a ranked
video on Google's homepage not YouTube I
mean there too but and if you see these
21 key moments if you click this it says
sensor size video resolution lens
aperture autofocus Auto features size
weight build quality selfie screen and
touchcreen record limit on and on and on
image stabilization by the way these are
my time codes and chapters so that's why
I would make the evidence-based
claim that time codes in chapters can be
incredibly powerful for ranking for
supporting like good content for Google
to distribute in a particular way and
bring you crazy like we get millions of
views a year from
Google on our YouTube videos because of
that exact thing happening someone
searching on Google finding a video and
then in doing so they could like be like
okay oh wait a minute clean HDMI and
live
streaming skip right to that point and
then notice this now is a player that is
YouTube and all of the in this video
things are over here uh all the
different chapters are over here so then
there's these links below it we would
get no credit for any of this stuff I
don't think where does this take
you you dog Google it just take it just
lets you search the camera and then take
it from whatever website you want um but
yeah isn't that kind of cool so that's
an interesting so how important are
chapters and how many well you need them
spaced out
uh you can't do less than 10 seconds
I'll leave it there just for time sake
to hit other questions because we could
go a lot deeper but I think you can
think about the pros think about the
cons you could do some testing um and
and I like to think about my final
thought is okay sometimes it might hurt
watch time but at the end of the
day and this is me even just sharing my
heart with you like we want to add
massive value to viewers we want you to
like have it be worth your time to be a
part of what we do at think media and we
want your experience with us to be a
positive one and I understand you're
like okay I've seen Sean you run ads or
I've seen your stuff or you're tell us
about your course my hope though is just
to build trust that you see how much
value we give and how hard we work and
also that you always understand that
like whether one of our products or
programs or books or something is right
for you cool then join this inside if
it's not cool like hang out on our free
content like like that is super chill
but that what the where I want to air if
I was going to air any on any side it
wouldn't be trying to like optimize
things just to like maximize what the
viewer could get but it would be the
experience they have with our brand so
here's what I mean if I lost a little
bit of watch time but you said the video
is so helpful when I come to think media
it's helpful I learn something it's
powerful it impacts me and so those
those chapters and time codes made it a
better experience for the viewer and
made that touch point with your brand
more memorable and more positive now
please forgive sometimes people go why
don't you time code a chapter this video
sometime takes
energy Sarah like sometimes you know why
isn't this pod code like we're trying
our best like this episode will be time
code and chaptered because we're doing
Q&A so we're not like withholding time
codes and chapters but but that's where
I a so I like I prefer to do them if it
supports the content even if the content
suffers because half of well a lot of
YouTube is about the algorithm and
optimization but let's never forget it's
about humans and and building a brand is
what do people think about when they
think about you what has been their
experience overall with the touch points
they've had with you and if you've ever
heard about the concept like jab jab jab
right hook that's also why you think
about it's not sometimes when you sell
something or you offer something people
are like oh you know now but the the
reality is when you do sell something or
offer something in a way that's kind of
a withdrawal and I like to think about
things in deposits and withdrawal and
Gary vu wrot the book jab jab jab right
hook meaning Jabs are like deposits of
value and right hooks are actually just
letting people know about how they could
go deeper with you and that you want to
have a lot of deposits of value and then
at times just let people know how they
could go deeper with you and so making
sure that you're doing as many Jabs as
possible as much deposits of of value as
possible you know in in marriage it's a
good thing any married people here like
marriage and relationships are deposits
and withdrawals they talk about making
deposits in your spouse's love tank
according to their love language and
sometimes if you're a smart husband you
think ahead and you're like okay to this
weekend my homies want me to go golfing
I know my account is a little bit low
right now so I'm going to do a few
things today a few things tomorrow I'm
gonna oh wow you organize the garage
yeah just you know oh wow like you made
me you brought me my coffee in bed you
got me coffee and surprise yeah you know
you make a few and then you go hey honey
question uh this Saturday I was thinking
about you know homies want to go golf
you know what do you think you know what
honey you deserve it you should go why
deposits and withdrawals so anyways um
that's kind of a side quest but uh I
hope uh there you go busy with dogs my
husband got me chocolate for no reason I
love it was it no reason
though why' you get me that oh no reason
reason
maybe but by the way and I'm not not
saying it's not a reason of course the
ultimate goal is to intentionally you
know I mean the reason is probably he
wants you to know he loves you he wants
you to know okay whatever marriage shvs
marriage Jabs and then marriage right
hook hey honey I was thinking about
buying myself fill in the blank the
thing you want to buy next um all right
so let's hit the next
question if you have three different
thumbnails and you realize your
performance on The Click rate is not
good can you give specific times as to
when to change and test them well here's
the good news generals Workshop is some
point it would seem to be a promise and
some channels already have it that in
2024 YouTube is going to allow us to
upload three different thumbnails and
it'll split test them decide a winner
and that'll be the final
thumbnail between now and then though um
what you can do is you can kind of Base
it off a hunch you can base it off of
you know if the video is underperforming
which we'll look at this so I look at
this in fact you know they say like
don't look at your phone when you wake
up like first thing oh yes I just get up
and I just float into the other room to
pray and to just wake up I wish that was
me man the first thing I do every
morning is I open up YouTube Studio I
just can't I do some of that I do that
other stuff as well I'm just saying the
first thing I do because schedule
uploads videos are scheduled uploads
typically on our channels at like 5:00
a.m. I'm usually up by like 6:15 or
something so I'm like how's it going 1
out of 10 10 out of 10 shoot and so this
morning I'm in slack before everybody
except for the people on the east coast
and around the world and I'm like all
right do we pivot the pack do we pivot
the title do we you know just kind of
thinking through and and looking at the
numbers looking at the metrics and
so um
the direct answer to your question uh
General Workshop is it's kind of like a
sixth sense that you develop because
sometimes I think you could spend too
much time like over optimizing something
and like depends on how big your channel
is how much momentum you have but man
I've been doing this for so long I can
feel it and sometimes I'm like okay we
missed it and so we actually have uh
like a new team member named Pierre
who's working with us and so like he
actually like hit me up this morning he
was like okay something here's the word
something's off on the packaging he also
has his own intuition he was like I know
the content is good now I know sometimes
we could be
delusional and sometimes we are like my
content is always good is it though
Sarah I mean relax I'm not talking to
Sarah if that's your name is just a
generic person but uh you know man this
video like is good maybe I missed it on
the packaging maybe I missed it on the
title the thumbnail and then what you do
uh General's Workshop is you look at
like the the curve and you just can see
if you can change that a little bit the
the launching of the video curve by the
way this video this morning I thought
it'd do better um this new tools for AI
content creators um is underperforming
so fewer VI viewers are choosing to
watch it and improving the title of the
thumbnail might increase viewership and
you could see this line right here and
there was no uh distinct real change I
mean made some changes to it so at some
point sounds awful to call it a lost
cause but you're like all right let it
go and try the next one and also never
forget because one of the things that
can happen this happens all the time in
our library you judge your videos Todd
Todd from YouTube said
this yes look at the first 10 hours or
four hours three hours of your video in
the first day and like think about
adjustments you can make but he was also
they give it time this is the engineer
of the algorithm Todd bu pre that was
saying saying you're underestimating
what YouTube videos can do in a week
four weeks 10 weeks we see a lot of our
videos pop off at 160 days 180 days and
they go from underperforming here to
overperforming through like the little
gray range
so whether that happens to this video or
not what I can tell you is you know you
may or make changes you'll see if there
can be a switch
up but then just be patient and then
just let it go
but a while back there was a video on um
on this channel 12 ways to 12 ways to
make
money uh new ways to make money with
YouTube with a small Channel and this
when this video came out I looked at the
packaging and I knew it deserved more I
was like I worked hard on this script
and you can't actually see it I might be
able to it would take too much time I
could look it up in our slack I got all
the screenshots but you can see how
small it was it was it was actually like
underperforming at the bottom of the
gray line so like actually look at where
it is now and it shot up as soon as I
pivoted things because I just and and I
could I could actually break down if we
were like gonna go super deep on that
could give you like distinctions about
how it went through that whole process
but I guess the bottom line to
oversimplify leaning on just saying I've
been doing this for a while I felt it I
looked at it I thought about the content
I've done I've here's a takeaway this is
one reason why you should start posting
videos keep posting videos be
patient persevere but also continue to
look at your data look at your YouTube
analytics because what gets measured
gets improved and also just by looking
and continuing to study and think about
differences that's where knowledge comes
from like and nothing can really replace
that experience so that's what I have
from just doing this for a while so I
felt it pivoted the thumbnail pivoted
the title that day boom so the blue line
was like this it went it just with
different
packaging it it took
off so I hope that helps uh General's
Workshop that ultimately um you could
pivot some things and Technical split
testing like trying something else is
not changing too many variables so it's
maybe changing just the title or just
the thumbnail and that would be the
database split testing but also what I'm
describing was like the human intuition
of YouTube experience-based where in
this particular case I made a change to
the title and the
thumbnail and then and had a hunch and I
I mean it's funny if you actually like I
I just talk to myself in slack too
because nobody's even awake I'm out here
because a lot you know what I don't know
whatever where even is the think media
tapam I don't know and so uh nobody's
even awake and I'm like talking to
myself I'm like maybe this will work or
maybe I just destroyed the video we'll
see and I like screenshot things and I
kind of make a history of it and like
just talking to myself and slack story
of my life all right so next
question what is the best advice for
picking winning topics for faceless
entertainment channels like uh
hockey I mean beer league hockey guy I'm
gonna recommend I don't know if you just
jumped on to check out the opening 20
minutes of this video where I talk
through those seven
research tools
opportunities methodologies and and
apply that because it'll work for
faceless as well smash like if you're
getting value we are 1 hour and two
minutes into today's stream we're doing
Q&A this is the coffee with canel show
my name is Sean canel for just meeting
your guide to building a profitable
YouTube channel and during the first 20
minutes of today's show we talked about
seven methodologies for coming up with
better better video ideas and topics um
Today's Show is brought to you by VR
podcast.com
so V is our YouTube online course and
our YouTube system we have tons of bonus
courses inside of a bundle that's
happening right now if you're interested
in that or maybe you're a part of our
challenge or maybe you've heard about it
you've been thinking about it for a
while is one of the best times to join
one of the other things we have is
Lifetime access and that's going away in
April of this year meaning it's not
going away for people who have lifetime
access it's going away for meaning
anyone up into that point is locking in
lifetime access we're going to be
switching to like a Netflix model and
you know that you cannot get Netflix for
life why because they keep doing
original content in fact I just uploaded
eight hours of brand new advanced level
content inside of video ranking Academy
and so anyone who's ever previously
joined over the past few months or past
few years you're just they're just
locked in and you can still get that
offer for a limited time so that's at VR
podcast.com and we finally we I mean
we've known we want to do this for a
while but we now have kind of mapped it
out and figured out our timeline so that
in a few months that's going away this
particular special offer has a couple
couple other bonuses and whatever all
the details you can check out VR
podcast.com and if you have any
questions you can chat with us over
there so on VR podcast.com you can see
how many hours are left because
depending on when you're watching this
there's 19 hours as of as of being live
on the offer that you can read about on
this page but see in the little lower
right hand corner we have um a little
chat bubble you can click so happy to
answer any of your questions here but I
want I can keep it on YouTube strategy
and tactics and you can see everything
that you get in inside of this bundle
including the YouTube road map Workshop
the AI for YouTube guide which is a
living document where we actually do all
the stressful AI work and find the tools
that kind of suck so we can lead you to
the tools that are great and uh we keep
that updated our YouTube shorts master
class or YouTube Niche Finder course or
camera confidence course uh the J if you
missed the challenge the the downloads
the recordings of our YouTube challenge
the workbook everything else so um
anyways that's V podcast .c we are
taking your questions related to
starting YouTube Right growing a channel
this year and uh next up we're going to
talk to the QR Queen about analytics my
shorts rank one out of 10 should I wait
24 hours to post again or are two posts
that rank one out of
10 uh what if there are two posts that
that rank one out of 10 H
well you know when a YouTube video is
uploaded and it's given a ranking short
or long form
video one out of 10 it just means
compared to your last ton up 10 uploads
based on that video's performance at
that exact time meaning at 30 minutes
it's one out of 10 at two hours it's
three out of 10 if it's a total Banger
it stays one out of 10 and actually when
you click into YouTube Studio on the app
or you go into your YouTube analytics
you could still see
rankings like 4 days later and they can
rise and fall okay so saying all
that
um there's no one answer to this
question there are YouTube shorts
creators that Focus like only on YouTube
shorts that upload three four shorts a
day they do great they do fine part of
it is just uploading the short now
ideally if you were going to upload Four
Shorts a day you would upload them at 9
a.m. 12 a p.m. 300 p.m. and 6:00 p.m.
there's no aren't magic numbers you
would just space it out at least a
little but the way YouTube works
is each video is judged on its own
merits
and if it starts to pop off and and get
suggested by the algorithm and hit
browse features or hit search or hit
suggested it's going to take on a life
of its
own however there is Merit to your
idea
that if you upload even long form videos
or short that they are competing with
each other they might be competing with
each other in subscription feed or just
YouTube's Rec recommendation engines you
know I don't know I can't they're not
going to blast all of your let me put it
this way people who really deeply
analyze all kinds of channels friends of
mine and we that's why it's cool like
our network is really strong of all
kinds of just different YouTube
Geeks what argue
that uh what is the best upload schedule
one a week if you could do it like
what's the next best upload schedule and
I'm talking long form two a week what's
the next best upload schedule this is a
quote from Matt
Gillan three a week is a sweet spot of
high quality High effort YouTube videos
separated by two days each so that each
video can perform do its thing and then
the next upload hits so then you go
aha I just found the secret to do you
know crushing YouTube it's three a week
two days apart but then Matt's next tip
was yeah
or like 10 a day like what he's like
yeah well I mean do you ever see WWE
Channel you know almost 100 million Subs
they uploaded 550 videos in the last 28
days like what do we talking about and
they're killing it you know so you go
550 videos divided by
31 days 17 uploads a
day and their channel is getting
550 million views a month from
uploads so anyone who tries to tell you
like there's some magic number of
uploads okay well what's the WWE come on
Royal Rumble let's get it on you know
okay they're coming to Netflix WWE
right you WWE Fan is it real you let me
know in the in the
chat so is there one right way it it the
I hate to answer the question like this
I wanted to give you data and then to
ultimately say like it does depend I
think it depends on also looking at your
channel looking at your content thinking
about your brand thinking about what
topics are you putting out there we are
always I love this tension this uh this
phrase of like a lot of things are not
problems to be solved they tensions to
be managed so we think of we just want
black and white answers when a lot of
things are tensions like the tension
between adding value and like selling
something the tension between um High qu
quality and quantity the tension
between am I uploading too much or am I
uploading too little and you're looking
for black and white answers I think we
need to
become um make datadriven decisions make
audience driven decisions thinking about
feedback we're getting look at the
numbers um and then continue to stay in
education things like this
because unfortunately if you live in an
echo chamber of your own
thoughts you'll come to wrong you'll
make wrong
decisions we all will because I see too
much information out there like oh
YouTube shorts you know killed my
channel now okay listen maybe that
happened for somebody but also YouTube
shorts changed the entire YouTube
platform like like the Shelf space like
on homepage is not just full length
videos but a short shelf on
desktop shorts are being recommended on
TV so shorts have taken
attention a level of attention away just
period a lot of people's channels View
are a little bit down overall and a lot
of people's channels are also not
thinking like oh shorts killed my
channel when not just looking at other
market
dynamics so all I want to challenge you
to do is to just think deeper and to
like question your assumptions to look
for data driven D driven decisions of
course if you feel like shorts and then
to do legitimate tests as opposed to
like read headlines and just Echo and
parot what other people are saying
because for the person who's like yeah I
post long form and short form I post
shorts and long form videos and my
channel didn't kill my channel and like
they're in the same Niche like
everything so it's like for anybody who
tries to make some factual thing it's
like tensions to be managed and so do
your research and then stay connected to
communities that's what I mean by being
a part of stuff like this the worst
thing possible could be that you get
locked in into some kind of an
assumption and this think it's kind of
scary like what do you believe right now
that's not true what do you believe
right now that's hurting you what are
you convinced of that's actually a lie
what are you convinced of that's
actually maybe partly true but it's
getting giving you an out for the work
you need to be doing or the way you need
to be pivoting your channel I know
that's hard and that's heavy but that's
also why we need that's truly why iron
sharpens iron we need outside
perspectives or just somebody like me to
prompt questions at you so you question
like some of the conclusions you've came
to because those conclusions could be
wrong and in doing so adapt your
strategy accordingly so um I hope that
helps QR I'm keep doing what you're
doing keep testing it keep getting one
out of tens like if they're both one out
of 10 keep doing it if things shift be
ready to Pivot skill number one 2024
agility ability to Pivot faster than
ever before because the world is moving
moving faster than ever
before all right five Canadian Acres
we'll see how long we can go but we got
some time when I put the question just
big I feel like I'm hiding behind the
question can you see me
still okay okay relax I've come up with
uh a style of gardening wholesome
gardening and want to start including
this as a base for my brand is it better
to just sprinkle it in or do specific
videos I I don't get excited about that
I don't and here's why so
like it's better to just sprinkle it in
if I'm answering your question directly
because I have no idea what you're
talking about and I think I'm G to guess
what you're talking about but now you're
sending my brain and probably the
viewer's brain I've I don't what do you
even mean and I
guess like wholesome gardening just
meaning your approach or like the
attitude you're going to have during
gardening or something I think just what
we need to remember is it's better to be
clear than clever when it comes to
online business online marketing and
YouTube and my opinion now I I'm coming
actually pretty strong here I think that
this ideology this
methodology
like who's that Maria condo what's her
book
called uh
book so what is her book The the
lifechanging magic of tidying
up the Japanese art of
decluttering and organizing
so I don't know if that's a
uh like a methodology but a lot of
people have done that and here's kind of
what I mean I would say your idea of
like wholesome gardening could very well
be like a book a movement an
approach workshops
Retreats finally someone came up with a
different way of doing gardening so I do
want to affirm that but I think
when it also comes down to like what are
people doing on YouTube no one's out
there like looking for wh wholesome
gardening you know when no one's out
there and a lot of times what they're
looking for is like a clear problem and
they're looking for a clear answer and
then to answer your question it'd be
like well if you pepper that in so I
would just make sure that your
video of course you should
include and sprinkle in constantly your
values beliefs unique things about your
personality that's what builds brand
that's what personal branding is I hope
you see though also whether it's
intentional or not it's not even just
this is a live stream what am I doing on
this live stream just being myself you
know people like your side quest like I
don't know I that's it's just who I am
you know so whether you resonate with
that or not or whether you know aspects
of my faith comes out as an overflow I'm
not like tactically do like it's just
kind of an over but our approach to
YouTube we want to help you be
successful on YouTube and have that
success without losing your soul which I
don't just mean in like a religious
context I would just mean in without
burnout without blowing up your family
without losing yourself in the process
with just getting sucked into chasing
vanity metrics and Views but actually
like losing your purpose or losing the
big picture so in doing so I maybe I'm
doing that's kind of my wholesome
garding is is Success without losing
your soul in the Creator
economy but I I hope we would see that
99% of this video is just more like
tactics and things like that and
answering your questions so I I think
that would be the model I think I would
do the same um and but just realize this
would be the mistake a lot of people
make I see it all the time is they do
come up with some kind of a proprietary
process or they come up with some clever
the clever thing if the clever thing is
your your framework or the thing that
you have to explain that's the big thing
like if when you're you're meeting new
people you don't want to have to explain
very much because they you have to think
about what do they know and what would
they understand and where you might
introduce event like for example V
framework the heck is that like what is
the V framework what even is a framework
what even is a proprietary process what
even is the unique think media
methodology like some people might be
able but so then I started asking okay
how do I simplify
that how do you start a successful
YouTube
channel and what are the
tips so I'm trying to think about a
simple way and then give some TP and
then be like if you want to learn
because I need to I need to explain this
so anyways I hope that helps that that
as people go deeper with you they could
get into like your wholesome gardening
methodology and
mindset but the danger is if I think if
you go too heavy with that
then people they'll just bounce because
they're like okay what are we even talk
I'm just trying to get my tomatoes to
not die I don't care if my gardening is
wholesome or not wholesome I just don't
want my tomatoes to die like and why are
my tomatoes so bad I just want to
tomatoes bad you help me make tomatoes
good like that like think it keep it
simple and as people go deeper with you
you could then
unveil greater levels of what it is
you're doing okay friends how long you
been here we're going to answer a few
more questions I'm just curious though
any aha moments from today and what are
your next steps we've reached the
portion of the coffee with candle show
where we remember that it's not just
about information but it's about
implementation and so I love reading
your what are your next steps what's on
your to-do list for your channel what
are your goals and uh what are you up
to what did you like best best from
today's Q&A so
far and uh someone said kiss with videos
it's good framework kiss I've heard
stands for keep it simple stupid kind of
a mean way of saying it is there another
way to say it but that's it is a good
reminder we also like to say we say asq
answer specific questions but one of the
Frameworks we teach just kind of deeper
on that is
assq which is answer speciic specific
simple stupid questions because the
stupid is kind of
jarring oh it's offensive okay relax but
it's it's actually that that being shook
a little bit on like you should answer
really basic questions that are so basic
they seem simp simple and they seem so
obvious that no one's making the video
and that's why there's an opportunity so
anyways talking about kiss talking about
keep it
simple keep it super super simple the
Kinder way the the more politically
correct way of saying kiss keep it super
simple all right do you use a funneling
strategy to drive traffic to Long forms
with
success I mean we use YouTube shorts
related
videos so you can now attach a related
video to a short and if there's if it's
a short of a longer video we use that
we've tracked it it works it's not crazy
I mean it leads it's not like oh and
then it went viral but it's a good
there's a good there's a few unique
strategies to that to that
um we I mentioned earlier how we might
use certain videos like like when I did
when I interviewed patri B David on a on
a private jet by the way we should read
the comments together on that video and
I understand people think I mean I I get
it they are like who are these
fake on a they rented this fake jet
to and he's got a fake Rolex and all
this stuff I'm like all right cool dog
you know whatever uh and I don't blame
people too like I guess it's fine um but
let's read the comments this will be a
fun experience so so what did they say
Let Me Go
new all
right okay time to decentralize mothers
okay nice plug opening sounded like an
infomercial thank you Brian appreciate
you nice Paisley Tai Patrick is the best
mostly mostly good but okay we can
always do
better okay maybe I'm just haters math
right you it's like one negative comment
um and so yeah like like this so there
was a lot because this video got a lot
of views I'm wondering if there's
actually flying a jet probably just
posted you know okay whatever that's
fine and so um what was my point um this
video I knew was going to kind of be
like a banger for us uh and and and so
you know the whole
story Patrick literally chartered a jet
to Vegas to speak at an event was went
straight from the tarmac jet running the
whole time to the event to speak for an
hour back to the tarmac and agreed that
he could meet up with me I just reached
out to him in DMS and I and I could roll
down there on a Friday night for like 45
minutes and shoot a quick interview so I
told like so I know people like oh you
just because you know you can like rent
a jet in La somewhere just take pictures
in like oh it's fake or whatever again I
don't blame people it's it's fine what's
the point so I knew this video was going
to be a banger so I did a YouTube video
I did a Instagram video with many chat
connected um and I said if you want to
watch the full interview comment Jet and
it sent people a DM with the link to the
video so I don't know if that's your
exact question but yes I was driving
traffic to a long form video on a
different social media platform and I
guess the other thing to say is with as
much content as we post or how much
energy this takes and this is
considering I have a team helping me we
don't do that very often but if there's
like a I think sometimes you should
think about in your library like every
month or maybe once a quarter you're
trying to put out a hero video if you've
ever heard the framework that there
is what like hygiene content Hub content
and hero content
and a her like a hero video that was one
of those ones where I was like if we do
this right it's going to be a big video
and it got 305,000 views so far and it's
still crushing and so my hunch was
correct and you know as a result of
course I'm GNA talk about that one a
little bit more on social and pump it up
and let people know about it because I
think they'd also be interested in it
and the whole thing was ridiculous like
actually what I did was I vlogged the
story because it was that's why I've
sent some people like the link to the
video they're like this is is fake and I
was like all right well I mean whatever
dog like so you know check it out and um
probably is sad like jet Studio or real
jet Jake asked and then people even the
worst place to film a prod I see the
crew you have to hold the microphone the
camera is so low you're putting nuts in
your face all right a little vulgar but
it's also like we didn't even know what
we were getting into like I'm sorry Jeb
like you know I know that art was in the
I UND it wasn't
like anyway it's just funny you know it
like people can have their external
perceptions of things I think that the
end result was pretty good oh we could
see the people in the mirror oh where
else were we gonna film this was like
the opportunity literally gets out of
the car and but again nobody would know
that context anyways and I digress just
in letting you behind the scenes in our
world and um yeah so so when you do a
hero video take away for you something
that's you put a little more energy into
to something that you put them I would
absolutely think about maybe supporting
that at times with some extra content
that you really polish for other
platforms with the goal of that content
reaching people so that you can even in
a greater way promote that actual video
and to be specific actually I realize I
can show you that that
video I can't see the comment numbers I
don't think but as far as how many
it's I mean I want to say hundreds maybe
thousands of comments and you could see
that uh here's the behind the scenes of
what it is so I ended up doing a
Instagram reel I was like kind of
vlogging vertically that day I did a
voice over of what happened these were
screenshots of the text messages because
even it was Friday night I was like even
the think media team that is actually
physically in Vegas had plans I don't
blame of course they do you know so I
ended up hitting up art he was like yeah
man um I got I got dinner with my
girlfriend I can't go I'm like all right
then he text me back he's like actually
she's not feeling with well I can go I
hit a brand he's like I'm getting done
filming another thing I can come so I
was I didn't even know as soon as
Patrick said yes then I was like could
this even happen and so it was kind of
its own wild story in and of itself and
uh anyways if you do a hero video you
can see all of this I haven't put this
Lev level of effort into a video since
that's about four months ago so you know
couple times a year go bigger and with
your res it's not about your resources
it's about your resourcefulness just go
bigger with maybe the research the
energy the quality of the video how you
promote it you're still taking a risk
it's no guarantee that that Hero video
is going to perform great but sometimes
we get so busy on just the day-to-day
stuff what if you slow down a little bit
and worked on a banger video like what
if you slow down a little bit and really
thought about crafting something that
was Next Level certain ideas that you
may see out there um they should stand
out to you especially over time where
uh you could get that we got and and we
ended up getting over a thousand DMS
Tyler told me in our private chat on
that from doing that Instagram and um it
ended up taking of people and then that
that auto sent them the link with a
software called many chat but you don't
even need that again if you start if you
see people doing this and they go hey
comment below checklist and if you want
me to send me your free checklist if
you're going to get like six comments
you don't need many chat or any other
software then click on the person's
profile and DM them and like copy paste
a little paragraph with a link to the
Google Drive be like hey here's the
checklist appreciate
you so you don't need any fancy software
you know or any fancy Tech to do some of
this stuff that'd be a way you could
Implement
that can
we
gently and
lovingly hit the like button if you
haven't yet I don't know if we've done a
poll we should be doing some polls here
are we doing polls tra um let's do a
poll and ask have you clicked the like
button unless we already
did um okay couple more
questions and we'll land the plane here
I'm having fun do I have like some
responsibility today that I'm missing oh
yeah I do at two o'clock I should
probably go I'm gonna answer a couple
more questions but I should go but I'll
answer one more question maybe two uh
awesome Drea thank you so much crushing
it we're I'm actually trying to hold
myself back from saying smash the like
button oh it's so cringe I get it like y
know just becomes habit so that's why I
asked you could you caress the like
button okay
what that's so
awkward don't how would you even do that
like yuck and your phone screen too is
gross oh makeup crusted on there sir and
salt from those french fries nasty face
oil all over your phone you know how
gross your phone is hey can I see your
phone you touch somebody else's phone
it's the most
disgusting
germ
accumulating anyways so caressing the
light button is probably a bad idea
because you're G like moving your finger
through some HD powder from
eelf what are we talking about this is
just what happens at that uh
okay we got more
questions we got more questions do we
need to put hashtags in all our videos
when we upload them number one no you do
not need to to put hashtags in your
videos when you upload them um number
two hashtags are really not that big of
deal number three it is my opinion they
also could be somewhat harmful so make
sure you you do your
research and what I mean is if I was to
do a hashtag like
hashtag YouTube by the way you could
actually go see if anybody even searches
the hashtag that'd be like thing one so
you come over here you go hashtag people
apparently search hasht YouTube poop I
don't want to click that let's check it
out like wait a minute what are we
talking
about okay so a lot of people using the
hashtag but if you were to say like
hashtag YouTube tips okay so if I click
that see the problem is if you were to
use the hashtag YouTube tips and then we
click through on here you then have to
ask yourself would it even lead to you
so if you're like trying to get
discovered for YouTube tips let's say um
then you got to ask ask yourself now in
our case we got John usai we got think
media think media to buddy I don't think
we're using this let's see Marcus think
media think media so so I would argue
like we could use this hashtag but 99%
of people who do would be if someone
clicks it because they they're
clickable it would lead them away from
not only your video but it would lead
them to a page where they're not going
to find you so now the hashtag has
technically become harmful like maybe
you
categorized so where there's a better
way and I think the better way is I just
like to use hashtags for Branding and
like categorization so that when people
click it they can find our stuff so my
hashtags typically are think media
podcast think podcast and Sean
canel and in doing so these clickable
hashtags
become th media podcast and if you click
that now other people could because
hashtags are are open for anybody to use
but now it just becomes a page not even
a growth strategy it's like an
organization strategy so people could
like search around other think media
podcast now Sean canel is interesting
because I might go on other shows and
stuff as I would and let me see here we
would go
to we have mostly our channels how long
until we find somebody else's Channel
how long until somebody else doesn't use
the Sean canel hashtag they should if
they have me on as a guest or something
maybe they don't I would swear that
eventually there would be it doesn't
matter but the punch is what what are
your like three hashtags that you want
to own and want to brand and then if you
go there I am so I'm on don't sweat it
with Andre jck this is actually like one
of the most underrated this is some deep
dive conversation stuff over here there
was two episodes this was the Afterparty
where I got deeply criticized from
shellene Johnson for sitting
cross-legged like what am I wearing like
what is this shirt and why look at
this like what is that happening in this
book like just sitting there she's like
don't ever do this again like my friend
shal she's like this is gross
embarrassing awkward and weird like Sean
you're better than this and I was like I
I mean we just got out of the sauna it's
like their show like they interviewing
you in a sauna and so this is part two
part one we're actually in the sauna um
but anyways they used the hashtag Sean
canel or maybe they didn't um and
because it's not clickable here and that
also just shows oh here you go so
there's a whole bunch down here and so
what happens too by the way is if you
have a podcast playlist or the videos in
a playlist that overrides the clickable
hashtags but notice at the bottom this
is not a bad idea podcast SAA Andre
Andre J first we Feast hotones what are
these hashtags what do they mean think
media Sean canel and that ended up
becoming findable of a guest you had on
or something else but also notice it
wasn't clickable so you just want to be
careful what hashtags are
clickable
above
your right there next to your views
because those could actually lead people
away they those could lead people astray
from your content if they're your brand
you're going to double down on your
brand and categorize all your videos
together and the advanced tip is kind of
what we just saw you can use more than
three if you want to get into these
categories like hashtag YouTube tips
just bury them they're not about being
clicked they're about an
optimization tactic I'm not saying it's
a great tactic but it's one of those
things where like beats a poke in the
eye beats a knife stab in the spleen
beats a kick in the pants like you might
as well optimize your videos in whatever
ways possible kind of like they did and
then there was some discoverability
there and you know um and those are some
tips for you on
hashtags my friends today's episode is
brought to you by VR podcast.com heads
up our special offer on video ranking
Academy and some extra bonus courses um
special pricing and locking in lifetime
access ends at the time of recording
this exact video in 19 hours so Now's
the Time if you're serious about YouTube
and you're ready to stop dabbling and
start dominating and if you're also
wondering again how is this different
than the free information and all of
that video Academy it's like a YouTube
College it's like over 50 hours right
around there of Deep dive in all to the
SE in all seven RS of our system you
know in the book Atomic
habits which I have around here
somewhere um James Clear talks about we
don't rise to the level of our goals we
fall to the level of our
systems that everyone's got the same
goals but not everyone's got the same
system and that's that's that'll help
you 2024 period get in shape um
strengthen your marriage it's like I'm
just trying to randomly hope I have a
better marriage but what's the system
for making sure you stay connected date
nights Bing Bong time is Bing Bong time
scheduled so we have a marriage
counselor this is Mitch and uh it was
just funny the other day she was like
you know once you're a parent and things
are kind of busy and you got young kids
and you got some different things
happening sometimes you got to
schedule Bing Bong time did you expect
us to be having this conversation today
on the coffee with canel
show that's a system now you have a bing
bong system you got a physical fitness
system you got a system for all the
different things and then different
aspects of your business in fact Nvidia
rag
Academy it we have our Sr system but
actually it's a whole program packed
full of systems like inside of the world
workbook you've got like whole
checklists and stuff and those
checklists the video creation
step-by-step plan there's like 30 of
those you know so we have different
because better to have a short pencil
than a long memory better to have
something where you can just check off
all the steps so you know you're hitting
it so anyways that's just what I mean
when you think about well Sean I listen
to the podcast or I've watched some of
your stuff yeah you're you're getting
some of the big ideas and some nuanced
tactics but what you'll find inside at
VR a podcast.com and our special offer
and inside of the course is just a
mastering a system and repetition is the
father of learning and the mother of
Mastery I think about one of the systems
that changed my life was Dave Ramsey's
Financial Peace University help my wife
and I get out of debt now he sh like you
learn all seven of the baby steps and
they talk about all the time but why do
you get inside of the program so it
transforms your thinking transforms your
habits and your routines and it helps
you hold and stick to the system and go
super deep at it in a Mastery l level
that's what you'll find inside of our
course if you're not interested no big
deal but just so you know there's a
limited time left to get inside uh with
this particular bonus
combination lifetime access and
everything else V podcast.com is where
all of those details
are and uh
LMAO Bing Bong appointments you know
what it is time to optimize for Bing
Bong time Bing Bong is physical fitness
it's a twoin one system my man you know
that's that's true um all right hey
Lauren I appreciate you uh V rocks uh
yeah if anyone talks about V we
definitely we don't like incentivize
anyone uh to uh say anything I
appreciate your kind words you know
Laura thank you for being on a stream
like this and being a part of the
V fam and uh bing bong has entered the
live some people being like okay uh what
type of channels game more success hey
friends I have a a stream that I'm doing
for a kind of a business group here and
I'm going get ready for that in the next
15 minutes but I do want to send you
love and respect gratitude thanks for
hanging out on the coffee with Kel Show
maybe you know somebody would love
content like this let them know about
this YouTube channel and the think media
podcast which is a two episode a week
Show new episodes on Monday and on
Tuesdays and Thursdays typically pretty
much always you're probably hanging out
with us here on YouTube but it's also on
audio if you're interested on all the
different platforms and this channel has
other shows like this beyond the podcast
and the clips we've got a live show and
so I can't wait until the next time we
can hang out if you turn on
notifications you can make sure you
never miss an episode of coffee with
canel where we will do future Q&A just
like this until then my name is Sean
kenel your guide for building a
profitable YouTube channel keep crushing
it and we will